but because I personally don't want to
take a woman that believes sleeping with
20 men is good for her like I I look at
her
um I look at her how she makes decisions
her decision making and I don't
personally think that's that's something
that that I want and when you say that
that's when people get mad and the
reason people get mad is because you've
been told you can go out and do whatever
you want and sleep whatever you want and
be with everyone of course you can but
it doesn't mean that you have access to
whoever you want and that's why people
get upset so by him saying that oh yeah
um she can sleep with 50 man that's fine
but I don't want her that's a preference
he's not he's not judging her if he says
that's a perfect example because bucks
they were so quick to jump on him yeah
but
what they didn't realize is that he's
out there racking up mileage
right bodies mileage whatever you don't
want to call it
and the women don't care